[Music]
anybody here ever have a uti you don't
have to share it but share it oh hell
yeah you have wait nah it's not for you
wait girls can get i mean guys can get
it too yeah dude i knew someone that a
guy who got it from somebody that we
knew you and everybody
oh you can get it like that i heard it's
quite rare
for men to get it
i think that the conditions where a
woman could pass into a guy has to be
quite light it's like a musket right she
has the yeast and you put the pound the
musket into the i wasn't thinking about
that but yeah i think that's a good way
to get if she has enough yeast in there
like quite
like the big bang conditions yeah i
think so that's what i've heard i don't
know the big bang conditions yeah one in
one billion right quite rare for a woman
to pass to a guy i never had a uti not
even in my butthole wow
so uh after a routine trip to the
doctors to treat a uti one woman
discovered a glass tumbler in her
bladder that had been lodged in there
for four years okay so a tumbler isn't a
tumbler this size
dude that's huge how the [ __ ] how did
she forget oh god
how does she forget me yo
what what the [ __ ]
wait why is it in the oh she's a fister
a tumbler i know but she's a fister and
to like exercise and work it out she's
probably trying different things and
then one time she was probably like
stretching with she didn't know yeah
she's stretching with the cup and then
like [ __ ] her mom's like hey help me
with the groceries oh [ __ ] and then she
just left and then she got distracted
and stayed in there what stretching is
she doing it's like when people
they do the gauge thing so they have to
keep something in there so the hole
doesn't close it's like a butt plug when
you're a pro anal or you have to do that
this was in her
vagina her vagina her 20s
it was a vaginal tumbler
holy [ __ ]
so bart's right about everything except
for the grocery shopping the mom uh the
fisting wasn't mentioned
everything but the vagina part pretty
much did she did she tell them how it
got there so she had also not realized
and forgot apparently too but yes it had
been lodged in there for four years
after inserting it four years that they
came out with a [ __ ] bachelor's
degree
[Laughter]
it took me longer bro holy [ __ ] man that
tumblr is coming out as a bachelor's
degree with a [ __ ] cap and gown
the tassel okay the 45 year old from
tunisia visited the hospital after
experiencing all the symptoms consistent
with the urinary tract infection she's
44
45 such as frequently needing the news
what they call it much to the woman's
horror scans revealed a giant eight
centimeter wide bladder stone why is she
shot bladder stone oh no what is this
i like the covering of the mouth yeah
what is this
that's crazy what country was this in
tunisia
so um yeah eight centimeter wide bladder
stone that have been growing for four
years encasing what appeared to be a
drinking glass
now bladder stones usually develop when
urine is not completely emptied from the
bladder
however in worst case scenarios they
occur as a result of foreign objects
becoming wedged inside
that's what it was it formed around it
so it's like a stone that wrapped around
the so this bladder stone is pretty much
urine that has like stoneify dude that's
actually more it's a kinder
surprise it's a kinder thing yeah yeah
like the easter eggs little chocolate
ones oh my god is that those uh bladder
stone things you you get when you're
kidney stones kidney stones i was like i
was like yes i literally just flatter
stones kidney stones
is that like a
like a frankenstein version of it where
like some people get small ones and then
they're like
dude a small one is enough to [ __ ] you
up dude imagine a small stone coming out
your pee hole steve had to go through
that
steve did that imagine going in i heard
people pass out
is it is it different for uh a man
obviously it's different but like you
know what i mean like a stone that's
passing through like a man yes versus
like a woman that i know it's a
different well anyways it's different
because it's a birth canal yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah men aren't
prepped properly for that to have a baby
come out of your shaft no
i've never done it before can i tell you
a story that this reminds me of of
course ryan has a story about this
it's
pretty [ __ ] embarrassing i've never
told it
my first girlfriend from like the um
like 1999 when i lost my virginity with
her nice
thanks
i used a condom
and uh it came off during sex
and i i couldn't find it afterwards oh i
know that's comedy that reminds me of a
story but i'll let you finish it when
she went to the gynecologist
and
it was actually in there for two years
holy [ __ ]
yeah wow she didn't get sick or nothing
she she like called you two years later
like oh my god hey they found it yeah
were you with her no we were not even
together anymore she was she in the navy
oh okay how did you ask how did you know
that it was yours
because we both were like
so that was our first time both of us
having sex we've lost our virginities to
each other but did you tell her like i
lost it i told her i couldn't find it
because i wanted to find it because i
didn't want to get caught by like my mom
changing my sheets or some [ __ ] so we
were both desperately looking for and i
was like
you don't think it could like be in
there she was like no way i would know i
would feel it
and then like she got too cocky she
didn't know until like two years later
she goes she calls me like we haven't
spoken forever and she's just like you
want to know something [ __ ] crazy
and she goes i just got a condom taken
out and it's that condom like
and so she did you have your initials on
it i thought she said like yo you marked
that terry's hair for two years oh man
if i just said like i just gave birth
with the baby an economy
and he's got ryan's facial hair
the baby was wearing the condom that's
why it came off the [ __ ] size what
were you saying about the navy yeah oh
no i just heard a summer story i have
one of our corbin on our teams he was uh
they do have rotation when we do the
medical portion of it but he had to pull
a condom out from some [ __ ] because she
had uh uti because the condom was in
there oh wow
can you imagine having for two years i
don't know that's why can you imagine
imagine like you're like you're like
[ __ ] a girl and then like and then a
condom pulls out and you're like i
didn't even have a condom on
and you pull your dick out you're like
why is the condom on now
stop saying [ __ ] like that nick is that
from a goosebumps book
can you imagine the skin oh this is it
for kids give me this [ __ ]
but i guess that's pretty common for
ladies to get stuff snuck up in there
huh i just didn't realize that she could
go that long and not know because she
was she swore she's like i would know i
would feel it it must have been pretty
deep in there you know
is it one of those things where you like
eat carne asada and then three days
later you're like what's that
oh that was from the barbecue
and you don't even know what's in there
i think it's similar
you don't know your mouth
we should ask her but yeah she's
it was a crazy thing because i had a
feeling i was like i don't know vaginas
very well i was [ __ ] 16. and i was
like but i i swear it's in there because
it's i would have found where else could
it be but it was on the back of your
shirt the whole time
for two years for [ __ ] two years i'm
just like he's still wearing the same
shirt
no none of his homies said anything
inside jokes about me that i'm like over
my head
it's conor shirt ryan dude
doctors have revealed that there have
been a relatively high number of similar
incidents reported among women who have
inserted foreign objects into their
their urethra for pleasure wow
so she basically
used a cup for a dildo just left it
there and said whoopsie doodle well i
mean
in in in this instance right obviously a
condom in a cup must feel very different
i'm not sure um but in this instance
there's this like if there was something
in me i would she could have been saying
there might be you know i mean more
complicated to understand but she's 40
not 16 and she has a cup and a [ __ ] and
she's like how did i get this
i mean and she has a stone around it
that's right i know she's like oh my god
how heavy you think that stone is
that's a great question because i wonder
if she got it out and she was like whoa
i feel so much lighter
i'm not sinking to the bottom of the
ocean
like can you imagine doing it and then
you're like man your [ __ ] feels like a
[ __ ] fight now
like feels like a glass cup
[Laughter]
you know what i mean like you would feel
like she was like
maybe she just is she like bigger maybe
there's um maybe yeah or like that shame
like i can't go to the hospital man like
this just one day it's gonna just [ __ ]
out i swear to god in my head when i got
my [ __ ] vertical cut on my ass i
didn't go to the hospital yeah maybe
that's what you just ignore it until you
do it but that's such a guy thing to do
you know i would just not picture a
woman and be like that they'll be like
oh you know what it's probably
reasonable to just go to a doctor right
now and get this cup out of my mind
i can't imagine a girl putting a cup in
her vagina either though maybe i just
live in a very simplistic world but i
just it's hard for me to imagine check
your dms in just a second
it's a picture of ryan with a company
it's two girls one cup i'm a woman
i mean it is heavy because that's like
that's like so internal and like you can
die like you could actually there's
probably a committee of cup bankers
right now watching this video like you
guys have no idea about our culture and
we don't know
please inform us like the committee of
cup bankers please
like smokers
you